(guitar strums)
♫ I'm blue
♫ If I was green I would die
♫ I'm in need of a guy
♫ I could beat off a guy
♫ I could beat off a guy ♫
♫ I don't think you're
ready for fish jelly
♫ I don't think you're ready for fi-- ♫
(slap)
(groans)
♫ Salsa on my balls, boys
♫ Salsa salsa salsa
♫ Salsa on my balls, boys ♫
- Weed brownie!
♫ Salsa on my balls, boys
♫ Salsa, salsa, salsa
♫ Salsa on my balls, boys ♫
- Weed brownie (laughs).
♫ I left my brains down in Africa
♫ I left my brains down in Africa ♫
(body hits floor)
- [Voiceover] Everybody get up!
♫ Baby can you breed
♫ A cactus from Jamaica ♫
(slap)
♫ It always works for me
♫ It's called a tooth decay-er
♫ Uh-Uh-Uh
♫ No more pretendin'
♫ Hey hey hey
♫ 'Cause now you're winnin'
♫ Hey hey hey ♫
- Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
There is a cactus right here, dude.
♫ Hit me with your pet shark ♫
(grunts)
- Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, I'll bet you think
that's really funny.
Well, you know what?
♫ I'm so
♫ fancy
♫ Can't you taste this scone
♫ Remember my name 'bout to blow
♫ Peace on the point,
hey yo, pass me the joint
♫ Imma spring this beat
♫ (indistinct)
♫ Oi chicka pow chicka pow ♫
♫ (indistinct) ♫
- Wallaby.
Iggy out.
- What was that?
- The greatest rapper alive.
(rap beat boxing beats)
♫ From the window
♫ To the wall
♫ From the sweatshop to the mall ♫
- Sponsored by Nike.
(bell chimes)
♫ Throw up on Mexicans
(man hurls and groans)
- Ugh, (speaks in foreign language)
(man whistles)
♫ I believe that the hot dogs
♫ Go on ♫
♫ Show me how to fight for now
♫ And I tell you baby
♫ It was easy comin' back to you
♫ Once I fingered an owl
♫ You were right here all along ♫
♫ She's got a chicken to ride
♫ She's got a chicken to ride ♫
- Wait, where's the chicken?
- I don't know, it was just here.
♫ Keith's got a chicken to ride
♫ But he don't care ♫
- Get outta here, Keith!
You're not in this video!
- Just let me do the one
chicken one.
- Give us the chicken, Keith.
- No, no.
- I'm not giving you the
chicken!
- Give us the chicken, Keith!
♫ Another good bop beep bah-dee-do bo-do ♫
- Hey, uh, what is that?
- Fallout Boy.
- [Boys In Back Together] Ohh.
♫ We're going down, down
♫ Doo be doo be do bow
♫ Sugar, we're goin' down (mumbles)
♫ (mumbles) ♫
- I'm gonna draw you like
one of my french girls.
- [Boy with food] This
one's gross (laughs).